hey 360 live here and Conan O'Brien a
little special treat I'm going to show
you behind my desk the back of the stage
right here no one has ever seen this
before and this is really incredible
first of all we have plants these are
not real plants these are made of
pressed aluminum and then they're
sprayed with a diamond mist and then
covered in a green ruby tint so these
cost up to $600,000 each here's my chair
legendary talk-show chair irreplaceable
or you could just go to any Home Depot
and get 60 of these this is the back of
my desk as you see it's worn away right
here from years and years of me grinding
my pelvis up against the edge when I'm
sexually frustrated this is a little box
where they keep different things here's
my guitar tuner I play a lot of guitar
at rehearsal so I tune my guitar this is
a device that has actually allows me to
manipulate the moon back there but I
never use it because it got boring after
the second time I'll deal with a lot of
very ill celebrities so I here's some
hand sanitizer spray that on keep things
nice and good here's some tissue right
here just random tissue in case someone
tells a real tearjerker this is a bucket
I throw up in if I really think that the
guest has got nothing and that's about
it here's my mug this is the mug I've
been using here at the show since 1993
my friend and former writing partner
Greg Daniels made this for me in honor
of me getting the late night show and
I've kept it on my desk ever since
along with Dwight Eisenhower because he
won the war for us d-day
made the big decision alright I've
probably gone on too long I just thought
you should see my desk
probably the thing year is gonna
remember the most is this area right
here worn away by my crotch rubbing back
and forth against it
after talking to so many very attractive
women and
being frustrated goodbye